The COO is the role of someone who
needs to be a jack of many trades and
a master of many trades.
That's a complex role.
It's someone who can drive operational
excellence, but also be able to understand
trends, create systems, put researchers
together to drive innovation.
The Emerging COO: Driving Innovation and
Operational Excellence, is a program for
current or aspiring CEO's,
is a program that
provides CEOs with frameworks to
help them become more effective and
successful in this complicated and
multifaceted process.
>> There's very few programs purposely for
COOs.
I was really looking for a hybrid between
the operations and the innovation so,
go figure,
that's exactly what this is tailored for.
>> To come together with a cohort who
really are facing similar challenges,
that community building is such
a big part of the program.
>> It's just so fun to hear about people's
challenges which are very similar,
I think across the board,
no matter the industry.
>> We have manufacturing companies here.
We have nonprofits here.
We have technology companies here.
And we were able to take all the data and
connect it to all of our organizations.
>> There's no recipe of what a CEO does.
Depends on where you are,
what you do and having that sounding
board in that role is really therapeutic.
>> We find that by bringing people
from different industries and
different stages,
we actually generate better ideas.
Being in the heart of Silicon Valley,
its exposure to really
the most innovative companies not
just innovative in technology,
but, innovative in organizational
practices, employee engagement,
how to scale,
how to grow quickly is really powerful.
>> Something that is unique is this
three month blended experience
that is broadcasting to three modules we
utilize a combination of online learning,
face to face learning, and experiential
learning at your organization.
>> Being able to practice and use some
of the concepts in a real life work
project is the key to actually getting
the most out of an experience like this.
>> A lot of what we teach and frameworks
that we share, arm you with tools and
a healthy dose of confidence that
you can take on the unknown.
>> I'm already thinking differently.
There's already concepts that I need to
share with the team that are either new or
things that are old but
they've been refreshed from being here.
>> The knowledge that I'm taking back
from this program will give the company
a huge advantage.
And to think outside of the box.
>> I think I had high expectations for
a Stanford educational program like this,
but it's exceeded my expectations,
for sure.
[MUSIC]
>> COOs are often times they
are unrecognized heroes in the senior
leadership seat of organizations.
They are the builders, the ones that
work quietly behind the scenes to make
the organization work and this is a very
optimistic place with a can do attitude.
COOs, we find it hard,
not to experience that.